في احد يحب يلعب العاب فيديو جيمز
هذا الشخصيه
قدرت ان انا اخلقها باستخدام التكنولوجيا
من غير ما يكون عندي اي امكانيات بدي اصمم
او ابرمج العاب فيديو جيمز
فمثل ما انتم شايفين كان شخصيه فعليه في
احد العاب الفيديو جيمز مع العلم ان انا
ما عندي امكانيه بهذا المجال
فالتكلوجي اليوم اعطتني القدره هذه انه
يخلق هذا الشخصيه ترى لما
اخوك محمد الشطي
الرئيس تكنولوجيا المعلومات في بنك فوبيان
وايضا مستشار في مستشفى السلام الدولي
كمستشار للذكاء الاصطناعي
حابه اسلط الضوء اليوم على مدى تبني
واستخدام تكنولوجيا اليوم في حياتنا
العمليه وايضا في حياه الشخصيه بما يخص
الذكاء الاصطناعي بالتحديد
وحطيت او شاركت معاكم دراسه فيها رسم
بياني تسلط الضوء فقط على اشهر خدمات
الذكاء الاصطناعي لانه ما شاء الله اليوم
وايد خدمات فانا حبيت اشارككم في هذه
الدراسه الدراسه تمت عن طريق شركه مايكنزي
متى تم الوصول الى مليون مستخدم بالنسبه
لهذه الخدمات التي تمتلك القدره على
الذكاء الاصطناعي
فبدايه من جبت 3 اللي انطرح في السوق في
نهايته
وجرب استلامه
وصل الى مليون مستخدم خلال 24 شهر بمعناه
سنتين
بينما قلت وصل بعد ست شهور الى مليون
مستخدم
وايضا دالي وصلت بعد ونص
واخر نقطه وصلنا لها اليوم وهي اشهر اداه
الذكاء الاصطناعي وصل الى مليون مستخدم
تخيلوا معاي بفم
فيبين لنا اليوم رسم البياني مدى تبني
وانتشار هذه الخدمات من قبل المستخدمين
الافراد في انحاء العالم
وانا حطيت مثال اليوم بالنسبه لخدمه دالي
دالي خدمه تحول النص كتابي الى لوحه
مرسومه فانا طلبت منها كمثال ترسم لي سوبر
ماريو
لوحتين كمثال
حاليا ودي اتكلم المنظور اقتصادي واجتماعي
وايضا اخلاقي
تكلمنا من شوي على تبني الخدمات بالنسبه
لذكاء الاصطناعي للافراد حابه اسلط الضوء
بالنسبه للمؤسسات
واخلاقيات العمل في استخدام تكنولوجيا
سمعنا كثير الاخبار اليوم ما بين من
استخدام وما بين تبني وخلق شراكات مع هذه
الخدمه
خلونا نتكلم شوي عن موضوع المنع او حظر
استخدام
اكثر الاخبار كانت
بالنسبه للقطاع التعليمي اطلعوا وكتب
دكاتره في الجامعات في مختلف الدول انه
يحبون يمنعون استدامه
لاسباب اهمها ممكن انه يكون راح يكون في
تحدي بالنسبه لهم
لتقدير مستوى الطالب العلمي بحيث انه
الطالب ممكن اليوم يروح يستخدم
اذا كان عنده مثلا بحث بقدمه او انطلب منه
وفي فئه قليله من الكادر التعليمي
احنا ممكن اليوم نغير اساليبنا في التعليم
ما نستمر على نفس اساليبنا اللي هي تعودنا
عليها من عشرين وخمسين سنه
انا والدتي احدى قيادات في وزاره التربيه
والتعليم سابقا فقعدت اسولف معاها
فقلت له
ممكن اليوم انه يحلها
بناء على الطالب
فقالت لي فعلا
احنا اليوم
فيها عن طريق استكشاف التعلم عن طريق
تحليل
التعلم عن طريق التلقين
فممكن اليوم في قطاع تعليمي نتمنى هذه
الفكره والتكنولوجيا ونغير اسلوب التعليم
الى عن طريق الاسئله
بالنسبه للاخبار الثانيه اللي هي تبني هذا
كان اصطناعي زائد انه
تكوين شراكات
شركه مايكروسوفت
تبنتي وحبت انه يكون احد خدماتها بالنسبه
مثل باوربوينت مثل وورد وكان هدفها
الاساسي انه تسهل على عملائها شلون يستخدم
التكنولوجيا بشكل فعال
في دراسه تمت من قبل تجمع الاقتصاد
العالمي اللي تاسس في 1971
ومقر في سويسرا التجمع يضم مجموعه كبيره
من الشركات وايضا الحكومات قياديين
مختلفات مختلفين
الدراسه تقول ان خلال 2025 سوف يتم
استبدال 85 مليون وظيفه على مستوى العالم
في حال تبننا هذه التكنولوجيا
بمقابل سوف يتم خلقه 97 مليون وظيفه جديده
فسوق العمل واحتاج وظائف لتم استبدالها
الناتج اليوم شايفين ان 12 مليون وظيفه
جديد راح تكون مطلوبه في السوق
في الوضع الحالي فهذا بحد ذاته خبر ايجابي
وليس سلبي ان تكنولوجيا اليوم
راح تعطينا 12 مليون وظيفه جديده في سوق
العمل فمن منظور الشخصي والمنظور المؤسسات
والشركات والقياديين
اعتقد في ثلاث نقاط نحتاج نركز عليها في
حال تبنينا هذه التكنولوجيا نقاط ممكن
تخلينا نستخدمها بشكل فعال وايجابي على
مستوى المؤسسات
اولا يجب دراسه اثار تبني هذه التكنولوجيا
على المجتمع بشكل عام من منظور اقتصادي من
منظور امني الموضوع اجتماعي فلازم يكون
الدراسه هذه موجوده ومدى اثر على المجتمع
بحيث انه
بنهايه تكنولوجيا اليوم لازم تخدمنا كبشر
ما تكون ضدنا
النقطه الثانيه
يجب تمكين وصول هذه التكنولوجيا لجميع
فئات المجتمع بغض النظر عن الشخص في حاله
الماديه الاجتماعيه ثقافيه لازم تكون
متناول الجميع بحيث كل استفيد منها على
مستوى حتى الشخصي او العمليه
ثالثا
يجب خلق ثقافه ونظام يعزز العمل مع
التكنولوجيا ما بين البشر والتكنولوجيا
اليوم الهدف الاساسي من تكنولوجيا مثل ما
قلنا تحسين حياه البشر
وبنفس الوقت
لازم يكون هدفها تعزيز الثقافه بالتعامل
مع التكنولوجيا وليس استبدال البشر
فهذا ثلاث نقاط الاساسيه باعتقاد الشخصي
في مجال التكنولوجيا لازم ندرسها وتكون
حذرين ونتمنى في مسؤوليه كبيره
بالنسبه للمؤسسات مع هذه الامكانيات
العظيمه اللي تعطيني اياها تكنولوجيا تاتي
علينا مسؤوليه اعظم في النقاط الثلاثه
بما ان شخص متخصص في التكنولوجيا
في قطاع الصحي
وفي قطاع المصرفي
في ولايه المتحده الامريكيه تم الدراسه عن
طريق شركه بي ام جي سيفتي
شركه متخصصه في قراءه جوده الطب في ولايه
المتحده الامريكيه
بيانات الدراسه
ان 12 مليون شخص سنويا
يتم تشخيصه خطا او تشخيص الطبي يكون خاطئ
بما يعدل كل عشرين شخص يوجد هناك شخص واحد
يتم تشخيصه خطا
هذه دراسه تعطينا دافع قوي اليوم ان احنا
نتمنى الذكاء الاصطناعي في القطاع الصحي
بحيث انه يكون يساعد الدكاتره جنبا الى
جنب
بحالات التشخيص لان الذكر الصناعي اليوم
امكانياتها كبيره في سته مجالات فهني راح
يعطينا ايضا دافع في استخدام تكنولوجيا
وليس الاستبدال دكاتره انما يكون شغال
معاهم جنب الا جنب
وفي ايضا
ابلكيشن اسمه بابيلون
حاليا مطبق في ولايه الامريكيه
ابليكيشن يخص التمريض
وبينه الدراسه بعد استخدام هذا اربعه من
العملاء او المرضى
معى للحالات المرضيه اللي معقده اللي
نعيشها اليوم فلونزا حراره كحه فتخيلوا
اليوم لو ندخل ذكاء الصناعي في القطاع
الصحي
مشكل راح يحفظ وقت للدكاتره للحالات
المستعصيه او المعقده مقابل ان الاشخاص
المرضى اللي عندهم حالات طبيعيه وعاديه
ممكن معالجتها عن طريق التكنولوجيا من غير
الزحمه في المستشفى او في المستوصف
بالنسبه القطاع البيكي
القطاع البيكي حاليا حاصله في ثوره
تكنولوجيه كبيره
ممكن الكل عاش هذا التجربه مقاتل في الوضع
السابق
في
مساعده افتراضي في امريكا
تبع بنك امريكا
قدر يرد على 500
الف سؤال وعمليه مصرفيه خلال عام واحد فقط
مع عشر ملايين عملاء
فتخيل كميه
نقول العملات المصرفيه اللي تمت من خلال
مساعد الافتراضي
مع كميه العملاء اللي هو عشر ملايين في
اعلان في عام واحد فقط
بالمقابل
الدراسه بينت واحد من العملاء مرتاحين
باستخدام هذا العامل الافتراضي او مساعد
الافتراضي مقارنه ويروح الفرع ويسوي
عمليات مصرفيه عاديه مالها اي تاثير على
مستقبل البشر
وفي ايضا اخبار طلعت عندنا في الكويت ما
عندي علم
في شهر مارس اللي طاف طلعت اخبار ان
الكويت كانت مستهدفه بالنسبه لعمليات
الاحتيال المالي
وتمت خساره خمسين مليون دينار كويتي وراء
هذه العمليات
شركه باي بال شركه مدفوعات الرقميه في
امريكا
عنده نظام منع الاحتيال المالي
مع ذكاء الاصطناعي في عام 2020
قدرت ان تحفظ وتمنع احتيال مالي بمقدار
مليار دولار امريكي فقط في سنه واحده
فتخيلوا معانا اليوم لو البنوك المحليه
تتبنى هذه التكنولوجيا وتستخدمها في مثال
منع الاحتيال المالي
ممكن ان يكون خمسين مليون للي ضاعت من
العملاء تنحفظ
وما تبغى سارتها
في نهايه الحديث حاب اشارككم وانتظر
الشخصيه
بحكم ان نشاص التكنولوجي في مختلف
القطاعات
التكنولوجيا اليوم لن ولم تستبدل اي شخص
ما في اي مكان عندما الاشخاص اللي
استخدمون التكنولوجيا هم اللي راح ياخذوا
مكانك
شكرا ويعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]